[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHANGYANG LINGHU: My
name is Changyang Linghu.
I am developing new
technologies for detecting
the symphony of cellular
activities in the brain.
The brain uses many
different kinds
of simultaneously interacting
signals to function.
All of the signals
working together
in harmony in the healthy brain.
To understand this harmony, we
need to measure these signals
at the same time.
Up to now, most scientists can
only image one or two signals
at a time, because the number
of signal reporters that
can be used together is
limited to the number
of available colors
on the microscope.
We have just developed
a new technology
that allows us to record
multiple signals in real time
regardless of the
color of reporters.
We call it Signaling Reporter
Islands, or SiRIs, for short.
It works by spatially
separating the signal reporters
into small islands
throughout the cell.
First, we engineer signal
reporters to self-assemble
into SiRI islands in the cell.
Next, we record individual
cellular signals
by capturing the light emitted
from individual SiRI islands.
Then we fix the cells and
perform immune staining
to identify distinct
tags bound to each
of the different reporters.
Finally, we attributed
the light emissions
to the corresponding
cellular signals
according to the
immunostain results.
We measured five signals
together in the first paper,
but we are working to
increase the number
to 10s of individual signals.
We're hoping that by
measuring multiple aspects
of the cellular
symphony in parallel,
we can pinpoint the
exact differences
between healthy
and diseased brains
and provide insights
into new treatments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]